what is going on everybody and welcome
to another video on the generative
python transformer so uh where we left
off
we were pulling a bunch of this github
data
and i'm going to go ahead and break it i
did add a couple of extra
little bits there and let me go ahead
and just break this first and then i
will pull
up what i've added here
whoops let me move this
and great
so um basically all i did
was because sometimes things might break
or whatever first of all there is a try
and accept loop
also i went ahead and am printing
out so so basically the
the new end time is whatever the last
start time was so yeah that's just my
note
to myself um and then basically as you
iterate through
okay we subtract a day from both of them
and then continue on
and then here basically every time i
just keep saying hey this is the start
time this is the start time that way
if it breaks or i break it and then come
back later or whenever i break it i just
paste in the new
um that previous start time as the new
end time
that way if we start back up for
whatever reason we're not getting
overlap of data
i mean we wouldn't i think it would just
say this already exists or whatever and
it just wouldn't do anything but
it would just waste time i think we have
enough directories to
not worry about it so uh so what is the
current
problem now um the main issue is
um let me pull up
here we go cool um so this is just the
linux disk usage
analyzer and then this is our uh
directory that we're working in and as
we can see the repos
is uh 394 gigabytes of
data um and that's from maybe
polling for six seven hours overnight
essentially
um it did stop a couple of times maybe
somebody could tell me why
uh there's a couple of it happens every
now and then where it asks you to log
in to github and i i don't i've never
seen that before where like you go to
just
get clone and then it says hey what's
your github login
um anyway that came up a couple of times
and i just broke away from those but
overnight after
like 3am or something it did that and
got stuck and then i restarted it and
then another one hit me
so um again i just broke and continued
um so i'm not really i was kind of
surprised that that happens but the
the other thing that i didn't understand
was going to be a problem
is the following like some of these are
absolutely massive so like this this one
here
we can see the single repository has
data that is 9.6 gigabytes so
again i always thought data was
you know the the largest file you could
upload i thought was 100 megabytes
um and maybe it got upped at some point
but i did not think you could upload
10 gigabytes and then so maybe it comes
when you do the clone i don't know
someone informed me there too i have no
idea how
how we got repositories that are that
large i knew it would be some
some sort of a problem but i did not
know that we would have so many
you know i mean i guess we don't have
that that many it looks like it is a
pretty rare occurrence but as you can
see as we scroll down we have a ton of
these
and like this is you know 300 megabytes
that that is not the python files
and all we want right now are python
files and there might be a way where you
could
um browse the files before we pull them
from github
so we don't waste our and github's
bandwidth i don't know that might also
be a possibility
again these are just tinkering episodes
so if we ever do get to the point
especially considering how long it takes
to to grab and how many total files
there are there are just so many
so if this is looking like it might
actually work
um i'll probably clean it up a little
bit and at least make the attempt
to not pull uh all the data
again just for my and github's benefit
but right now
we're just trying to test and we're just
trying to do things as quickly as
possible so
um so right now the main issue is we
have these huge files and
like 400 gigs i mean i've got some space
but i'd rather not um use that much
space
so there's a lot of files here that we
just we we simply don't need so
what we're gonna do is the smart thing
which is to
just automatically with python just
parse through
all of you know a bunch of these
directories and just wildly delete
probably 300 gigabytes worth of stuff
um what could go wrong so we're going to
use
uh os walk most likely
and then os dot remove and hopefully
all the recording doesn't just randomly
cut out what as soon as we run the
script
and i've deleted everything on my
computer okay so
um so yeah so that's what we're gonna do
and um
cool so i think i'll minimize that it
took forever for that to come up i
think because there's just so many
directories um
and cool so we'll save that and now what
i'm gonna do is come over
to yeah and
uh let's just do a cleanup so let's do
this copy pasta
rename and we'll just call this uh
cleanup non-pie
dot pi beautiful uh the next thing i
want to do
before we get too deep into it um
so obviously i left that running wow
repose um oh you can't even see that
just barely off the screen anyway so
we're going to check the
the size according to this because i
can't run the disk usage analyzer again
sometimes you see deferring numbers um
between the two i don't know it's it's
uh
very complicated stuff um anyway
apparently that's going to take a while
but
usually that's pretty quick there it
goes okay so 400 so actually
we're at 414 gigs and again one
thing is i do notice often there's a
difference in values
between using this command and like disk
usage analyzer or if you check
properties
and then the but it's usually relatively
close
but then also i left it running while i
was setting everything up
uh in the disk usage analyzer took
easily 10 minutes to load so
it's like an extra 10 minutes of data so
anyway that's the discrepancy there
um so okay so that's how big it is
right now so what we want to do is we're
going to severely trim this
and um i think so that we don't lose
like everything we've done up to this
point because that would be super sad
um we're going to say repose
uh test and what we'll do
is we'll just grab some files from
in here um maybe here
to here copy i'll paste those into here
and cool so that's what
where we'll do our testing that way we
don't accidentally delete like
everything because this this
can run quite quick so um
yeah so now we can just do a quick this
should go pretty quick
quack pretty quick uh
dang it doesn't look like we're gonna
have i mean 60 megabytes
that's okay well we're definitely to
remove some stuff so it looks like
they're start it's starting at 60 meg
so now uh clean up
uh now what we'll do is let's make sure
everything's good on screen
and maybe zoom in a wee bit cool
so um so yeah so what we want to do from
here
is just simply um
we're going to import import os and i'm
going to grab
my latest favorite import of all time
and this is just so we can do cup pretty
colors
um and now we're ready to
walk so what we want to do and i always
forget
the order of walks so let's open up a
terminal right quick
um we'll do python3
and then we'll import os
and then i think it'll be help os dot
walk
okay so this just reminds me of what the
order is here so
so with os.walk there it's a
tuple and it has three values in it as
you
continue walking so you have and then
also
okay sorry so as you as you walk through
um top down i forget what top down does
we'll just leave that alone for now
follow links false we don't probably
don't want to do that
and uh okay so i think we'll just
specify the top directory
uh and then what we get back is dirt
path through names file name so we'll go
ahead and just
copy that we'll quit out of this and
uh quit here
cool so um
let's go four uh
for paste der path third names
uh in os dot walk
um and we wanna walk the
test directory so repos
test stopwatch repos test
and then what we want to say is
uh for der path
der names uh let's print uh
print
uh dur path
print der names
and then print file names
so i want to say this will give you the
name
of directories within
the dir path and then this gives you the
list of
file names um within the der
path so we're not interested in dirt
names
dirt names is just going to be uh you
know recursively walked through by
os.walk
this is my understanding anyways so
really if we want to get the full path
to any specific file
it would just be
print os.path.join
uh der path no
dirt path and file names cool so
actually
let's just say here full path equals
and we'll say equals this
okay uh comment that out
um so i think
i think we'll just run that real quick
and see what happens so we'll print
a full path and let's go ahead
and break
uh file oh
dude so so we definitely need to do uh
for uh
file for f in
file names
direct path f
um okay so in this case we'll do
this
that is not oh what's up have to join uh
we want to
say full path is der path
and f for f and file names
so we printed all this for f and found
it so maybe
so apparently we had no file names
repost test
okay fine import time
and um let's go ahead and
time dot sleep uh
we'll do a half of a second we are going
to on
uh un-print those things we're gonna
come over here
uh we're gonna say python32 cleanup
okay so apparently i'm a big dumb dumb
uh what have we done what am i missing
here
oh we're still breaking here
so if this works i'm gonna be so angry
are we gonna sleep still let's check
that yes
okay so we can hold a break
oh gosh all right uh
are we ever going to see a dot pie file
that is the real question
so repost test oxff hacking stuff
great um where are your pi files brother
[Laughter]
where are you there we go there's one pi
file okay so
okay so we are getting
disco uh
okay anyway uh we are getting uh
example files so what what are we
what are we going to teach this machine
to do
uh there will be hopefully other things
um okay so
okay so we are getting the full path um
apparently i just need a little more
coffee in the system
um but we we are actually getting it so
the next thing
is going to be uh
if if full path dot
ends with is it ends with or ends
we're going to find out very quickly i
think it's ends underscore with probably
uh dot pi um
we are uh i kind of want to google that
but we'll we'll find out the answer to
that without
looking it up uh if full path ends with
pi
uh print and then we'll say uh green
uh full path
uh in fact here's what we'll do we'll
say uh keeping
keeping
full path and then else
will print red
deleting full path
okay so now we will see uh we're not
actually taking any action at this stage
so we don't need to sleep for the moment
uh and let's come back up here
and check that oh we need to get rid of
some extra print that we're running
right so this is looking good so the red
stuff is the stuff that we're going to
delete
cool the green stuff is the stuff that
we're going to keep because we want to
keep all those files looking good
looking good
um okay so i think
we are ready for our very first test as
a reminder the initial size of that
directory
uh was what 60 megabytes it was like
59.9 i think
um so the last thing that we're going to
do is
os dot remove good luck everybody
oh god um
oh esta walk walks that repo i think
we're gonna
we should not need this but uh let's say
uh
the dur that we're going to check is
going to be repos test so we'll say d
equals repos oops repos test
and then um
i just don't like deleting a lot of
things so
it always makes me nervous uh we should
not need this but just as a
total backup fail-safe if
um if d in
full path uh we'll go ahead and remove
else print
yellow just so we can see it uh
something is wrong
we should never see this
something is wrong uh time dot sleep
uh 60. hey you jerk
okay hopefully we never see that but
just in case
i'm going to have it there
just to make sure i didn't do anything
silly
okay i think we are ready so it was 60
megs
now
many things have been deleted the
computer still works
we're good i think i hope i pray
uh okay we will test repos test how big
are you
so it was 60 megabytes now it is 7.8
i not gonna lie i kind of expected it to
be even smaller than that but
okay um i think
uh i think we're ready to do it to the
big boy now um
let's just i guess we'll we'll make a
quick test here so okay arp okay all
that's in here are python files
hopefully
um i mean i guess if we ran this one
more time
we should see nothing but green right
yeah
beautiful beautiful look at how pretty
this is
well okay yeah we ran it there cool
okay yeah let's do it
let's delete a ton of stuff so
uh so we'll do repose remember it was
what 414
uh when we tested it i think it's i
think we tested it probably here but it
was
um okay so we changed the directory to
repose
final sanity check before we just
recursively walk and delete stuff with
programming what could go wrong
no i don't nothing
[Laughter]
and we're off uh the prints are actually
probably
slowing things down a wee bit um
and in fact um
we could stop it at any time and restart
it part of me wants to stop it
and remove all of the prints other than
that that like yellow print
i think it will be quicker than than
printing it out i mean it looks like
it's working um
this might take a long time there's a
lot of files
yeah i'm gonna go ahead and break it uh
and what we'll do is
uh we will
uh just pass uh
else red um okay cool
so hopefully now we will
well now we have absolutely no idea
where we are in the script so i'll let
that
uh continue to run while we come over
here
and uh import uh
uh import tq dm now i feel like my
sometimes my brain just doesn't work i
can't recall
if it's from from tqdm import tqdm
it might actually be we'll find out
momentarily
yeah uh from
tqdm import tqdm
oh you're not gonna give me a progress
bar huh
[Laughter]
okay okay
how come i don't have a progress bar
do i need to search that one
uh tqdm progress bar what is
what have i done wrong here
cool um
oh well we're done
okay that's fine uh all right
moment of truth moment of truth
uh go back here repos oh
well actually the true moment of truth
will be
uh what is it do sh uh
repose
18 gigs i cannot believe it's 18 gigs of
python only files
um but anyway okay that's what it is i
guess
um gosh that's so much
python what the heck 18 gigs
are you sure that's so
much python um
anyway okay so it apparently is 18 gigs
that's obviously better
than um what we had before which was
414 gigs so we can obviously download
way way way more data um probably pretty
soon i think i'll
keep running the polar uh keep getting
some more stuff and then i'll keep
cleaning it up
uh like using the script um i haven't
really decided or figured out how many
gigs of data should we even have
um so i don't know uh but i'll probably
pull a little bit more i think i can
have probably
i don't know 50 to 100 gigs worth of
stuff i think that would be probably a
comfortable starting point
uh and have plenty of code the other
things small things are
things that could be problematic are
things like forks
uh stuff like that so we're gonna
probably have a lot of like repeat in
the code
um from people who have like forked and
then continued work because i think
when you fork it's still going to call
that new
forked repositor the fork it's going to
say that was created
on some new day so some of these
repositories are probably going to be
duplicated
through forks now i
i don't really know if i i mean i'm sure
there's a way to handle for that
um i'm not sure it's necessary because
then
the more popular some sort of python
package or repository is the more it's
more it's probably going to get forked
and then it's just going to be better
represented in the data set so i'm not
really sure
i'm not really sure that's going to
matter um but
who knows so anyway cool so we've
cleaned that up
uh we are now having a much smaller data
set and then we can just keep running
this as we
as we download the data um i think like
i said i'm going to continue getting a
little bit more data from here
uh and then probably puts more thought
into
at least the first test you know
building that data set for the first
time
how exactly do we want this to work out
um
and then train from there so so anyway
that's it for now if you've got
questions comments concerns suggestions
uh whatever you know the deal you can
leave them below otherwise i will see
you guys
in another video
you